[Musique]
la comédie française le danger pour vous
était de rester entonné dans des rôles
de perpétuels ingénue aussi très bien
que le danger est en effet de vieillir
et d'évoluer et de ne plus pouvoir jouer
ces rôles de jeune fille
quand on ne peut pas vraiment se diriger
vers d'autres rôles
c'est ce qui s'appelait l'emploi et
l'emploi était très défini la comédie
française
on n'aurait jamais envisagé qu'une jeune
fille d'un médecin quand huit c'était
mon corps puisse jouer par exemple une
jeune coq est une célimène c'était
impensable si les mène et les coquettes
était jouée par des femmes qui avaient
ce qu'on appelait de la prestance et une
taille élancée d'au moins 1 m 65
mais il est arrivé à la commune i
français un homme qui a balayé tout cela
en 36 qui a été administrateur et loire
bourdais edouard bourdais était l'homme
de théâtre que vous connaissez
prodigieusement homme de théâtre et il a
dit mais cette petite relouer
excusez-moi paiement surnom cette petite
renault doit sûrement pouvoir faire
autre chose on va l'essayer tant pis
c'est risqué on va l'essayer dans son
premier rôle de jeune femme est bâti m'a
confié mon premier rôle de jeune femme
jacqueline du chandelier d'alfred
gaullisme et le risque qu'il a pris
s'est terminée par un succès oui ça a
été ça a été un beau succès puis vous
savez au théâtre quelquefois tout
concorde
figurez-vous que c'était l'année aussi
où j'ai connu jean louis alors il est
devenu dans mon coeur et dans mon esprit
et
fortunio de jacqueline est vraiment
quand je j'allais en scène et bien je
pensais à jean guillon en jouant
jacqueline et en faisant mes
déclarations d'amour et un ange roland
faut que tu me et ça vous croyez que
c'est ça que vous a donné une flamme
particulière qui ont à viège à mes yeux
à 20 ans
si un contribuable certainement je crois
beaucoup aux reflets de notre vie
personnelle sur scène et dans nos
interprétations j'y crois énormément
moi j'ai l'impression j'ai jamais été
seul dans ma carrière puisque j'ai
toujours à parthenay une proue comme je
vous le disais mais j'ai l'impression
que ça doit être terrible et tout d'un
coup tout seul dans son métier dans la
tellement dans quoi ce à la veille d'une
général vous comprenez on aurait
vraiment qu'on joue sa vie à chaque fois
chaque fois et comment je recevais vous
l'échec si vous le recevez mal pendant
24 heures
on a le cafard qui on veut on veut
renoncer à tout ce temps là les vivre à
la campagne on veut tout vendre on est
désespérés ou doute et au bout de 24
heures et bien c'est avaler moi je dis
toujours aller à valleau et puis on voit
là où on recommence en continu plus tôt
[Musique]